Yeah,
now's the time we break out the elan Musk weed.
Oh my God.
That was crazy.
I watched every minute we drank whiskey food,
two hours.
When I say crazy,
I mean like an amazing get journalistically.
I was awesome.
No,
it was really cool and I have to thank some of his friends that I'm friends with
that convinced him to do that.
Yeah,
that was a fascinating conversation.
I thought it was nothing.
I thought so.
We smoked a little pot.
I didn't,
I literally didn't think nothing of it.
He does.
That's what,
what,
what?
I really wanted to talk to him about what his thought process,
like what,
what's going on.
I know something different.
It's going on in his head.
You know,
you ever talked to someone where you know,
because I have children and I do like to think of people's babies that become,
you know what?
They are see them in front of me right now and there's a constant state of
evolution,
but sometimes I'll run into someone that's depressingly stupid where I realized
like,
God damn,
this guy's got a nine volt brain.
They just do.
Some people just do and no one wants to admit that.
And we're not talking about mental retardation or any sort of a disease down
syndrome or something like that.
We're talking about people that are just toxic,
really stupid,
and they do exist.
Just like some people have big noses,
some people have little noses.
So when you were talking to Elon Musk,
did you get the sense that you were talking to like a genius?
What did it feel like?
I'm a chimp.
Like you're that person.
That's exactly what I was gonna say.
I am that toxically stupid person talking to this guy really wants to create
gigantic power stations in Australia to fix their grid and wants to shoot
fucking rockets into space.
And they literally let them drill under La.
They're like,
go ahead.
What are you going to do?
We're going to drill holes.
God,
people are completely fascinated by him.
And they would have watched you.
They would've watched like a silent movie with you and him for two hours.
Millions of people would have watched that.
I don't know about that.
I didn't want to hear him talk for sure,
but I'm saying like anything he does is completely fascinating to people.
Well,
he's a little Gitelman super genius.
I mean,
legitimate,
like when he's not full of shit is that his,
his,
his thought process is extraordinary.
But one of the things that was really clear from talking to him was that it's
uncomfortable that his whole life,
it's been this tornado of ideas,
it's be going against his head.
And he,
he's like,
you wouldn't want to be me.
And I'm like,
what do you mean man?
You know?
He's like,
that's it.
It never shuts off.
You know?
And they're like,
oh,
but he wasn't,
you know,
he wasn't,
woe is me.
He was being factual and he was probably,
it's probably like,
you know how some people have a ringing in their ears?
They have Tinnitus,
rock concerts,
too many.
I think he's got a ring of ideas.
So while you and I are having this conversation,
I don't have a fucking thing else going on in my head.
There's nothing,
there's nothing else back there.
It's just you and I talking.
There's no fucking grand plans.
I think he's like remapping civilization and trying to make a yacht.
You know,
it's,
I'm thinking I want a burger.
That's what I'm thinking.
Yeah.
Um,
he's,
he's just,
you know,
just like Shaquille O'Neal is eight feet tall and some people are four feet
tall.
You know,
some people just have a brain.
I mean,
there's,
there's no,
there's no level playing field when it comes to anything politik performance or,
or mental performance.